hello everybody so I have to apologize
first of all some of these videos that
I've been making the reason ones have
been very personal I'm going through a
lot of personal stuff and somebody know
my family has been flooded we're still
in kind of absolute chaos right now as
you can see I'm still so my parents
house for luckily I have wonderful
parents I'm still there for a little
while we able to rent a house for my
family until everything gets set up the
the government as you as some of you if
someone you haven't followed the story
there's a dike that broke in my town and
about 2000 like 6000 people were
evacuated to 2500 houses were flooded
and so it's absolute mayhem in the city
you know that my street looks like a
post-apocalyptic movie and so we are we
are able to strip everything remove
everything from our basement you know I
lost my all my my books yeah you know we
lost everything that was that was in the
basement
um and so the government has said that
they are going to rebuild the dike
finally and so they hesitated for a
while they're going to rebuild the dike
but the city told us to be very patient
because they need to decide which areas
of the city will now be considered
that's a floodable area or uninhabitable
area and so they want us to wait before
they rebuild because some people will be
expropriated so we don't know who that's
gonna be
we're far away from the water but our
our house is one of them is one of the
lowest on the streets and so we're not
sure whether or not we will be one of
the people who will be in fact be
expropriated anyways so that is the
situation we had amazing people helped
us so many people have been helping us
to clean up the house my family friends
even people who I'd never met someone
Mike forget is Mike McDonald came from
Montreal I never met him came by bus and
he came to help us
helped our family so it's been just that
has been amazing just being surrounded
by people who have helped us a lot of
people have also sent us money through
PayPal and several people have asked me
to set up a GoFundMe campaign so that I
did that today I will put the link in
the description for those who like to
give through GoFundMe and kind of see
you know that the amounts go up and get
a sense of of what kind of donations
we're getting so so if you want to
support us right now I don't know what's
gonna happen I've no idea everything is
completely up in the air I haven't
worked in several weeks and so I I'm
grateful for any help right now because
I don't know what's gonna happen so but
still next week I'm still going to be in
Seattle now I'm giving a talk there with
father Steven Freeman and then you'll
forget his last name I'm sorry beacon
Daniel and and so I will be there so if
you're if you were planning to come to
Seattle don't worry that's gonna happen
I'm also going to be in Louisiana in a
few weeks that's also not going to be
canceled and I'm also giving my carving
workshop in the beginning of June so all
of that is going to happen so if any of
you have been wondering whether or not
those will be canceled none of those
will be canceled so all right so for the
subject of this video I decided I'm
going to talk a little bit about what I
would call the thrill of death
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so it's based obviously right now it's
based on my appearance it's based on
kind of looking inside and realizing
some of the emotions that are going
through me and some of the experiences
that are happening related to a lot of
the symbols that I'm talked about in
terms of exploring the symbolism of
periphery and the symbolism of this
crazy upside-down chaotic world and so
being kind of confronted with that
directly in this flood you know talk
about the flood and so being faced with
the flood really brought about a lot of
obviously some despair obviously some
desolation sadness anguish all that of
course but I think the most surprising
thing to me that which is why I want to
talk about it because it's surprising is
the this weird thrill that also comes in
these moments and it's not the first
time that I felt this it's also not the
first time that my family and I have
been in a situation which is similar to
this one several years ago in 2004 I
think it was my wife and I were in Congo
and we were visiting the east of Congo
we're all were visiting the Great Lakes
area we'd been to Bujumbura and we were
visiting we were in Bukavu which is a
city on the east in the east of Congo
and while we were there were there for
just one day and coming back from
through Rwanda and Bujumbura coming back
towards Congo while we were in Bukavu
there was a war that started we were in
a guest house and all the sudden started
shooting my wife actually I was insane
because I was deathly ill I don't know
what I eaten in Bujumbura obviously
sometimes in Africa you eat stuff you
know you get food poisoning or you get
you know bug and so I I actually took a
bus from through Rwanda for it was like
an eight-hour trip and I had horrible it
was horrible even every time the bus
would stop I was like run out into a
field sorry for the discussing details
guys but I had you know just horrible
stomach stuff so we get two bookable and
I'm dead
you know I'm lying in bed just kinda I
just want to die from my stomach issues
and my wife says I'm gonna go eat so I'm
like yeah you go eat I'm not eating
anything she goes out into bukavu to eat
all the sudden I hear this obviously
having been in Congo already for a
little while I know right away what's
going on you know hmm
but I'm so out of it I'm just laying
there for about two minutes I'm just
laying there and I'm listening to the
shooting increase increase increase and
then finally dawns on me okay
something's going on like they're
shooting outside and my wife is not here
so I like you know I put on my clothes I
get dressed and I go out to the door
they don't want to let me out of the of
the compound but I'm like I need to go
see if I can find my wife I think she's
right up the street so I get out of the
building I run up the hill and there's
my wife like coming to join me and
everybody is kind of running around in
the city and everybody's there's a weird
vibe going on so we go back into the
guest house and all of a sudden we
become just locked in and the the
shooting the machine gun shooting turns
into heavy machine guns turns into
shelling after a while the ground is
shaking the building is shaking and we
are stuck in this guest house I'm got
stuck in the get we got stuck until the
evening and then in the evening they
were able to negotiate a ceasefire and I
slept because I was so sick I just left
all night and the next morning my wife
got up and I'm like I need to sleep on
you sleep and I just I just slept except
for hours and the shooting started again
and for some reason I was just able I
just slept through the shooting and it
was just shooting and shooting and
shelling and I slept for a few hours in
the shooting it just reminded me you
know of that scene of Christ in the boat
down in the bottom of the boat not that
I'm like Christ but just the scene of
Christ in the bottom of the boat as the
storm is going on and he's sleeping in
the bottom of the boat or Jonah you know
in the bottom of the boat sleeping I'm
into this total absolute chaos and so
I'm sleeping in the bottom and sleeping
in my room and after a while it's just
too much I get up and I and I get out
and it was so surreal because the
shooting was so intense the sound was so
intense but inside the compound was this
beautiful garden and so I took a picture
and in the picture it's just this
beautiful garden and you can't hear you
know the the insanity that's going on
outside so we get stuck in this place
and we're trying to be evacuated but
they keep calling the UN to come get us
but the UN says it's too dangerous they
can't come get us at all
so finally because also the you would
the head of the UN was Swedish and we're
at the Swedish gas house so they had a
personal connection with the head of the
UN there so finally they are able to
convince the UN to come get us because
the shooting has died down then you go
she ate at some kind of ceasefire and so
then I have to go but still shooting I
mean it still shooting pretty intensely
it's just maybe not shelling I don't
know why they decided that they could
come but there was a shooter right on
the top of the wall of the compound we
don't know him which side the shooter
was but I decided I'm gonna go back to
the room go outside into outside into
this outer compound and then walk
through the garden and then go to our
room which was like kinda like a motel
situation with the door on the outside
to go into our room get our stuff so
that we could be evacuated and so I get
out of the room and then as I get out of
the room and start shooting and shooting
and shooting and I'm going towards the
room and there's bullets whizzing
through the trees above my heads above
my head and I just remember that feeling
and this is the feeling that I'm telling
you about
I just remembered this absolute thrill
like this rush this rush of strange
energy this rush of it's hard to explain
I mean I think it's not that hard to
explain a lot of people that's probably
why a lot of people get into extreme
sports and those types of situations
where they put themselves really close
to death and they can feel this this
rush you know I've done some rafting and
that kind of that kind of a sport where
you can feel a little bit of that you
know are you go on a roller coaster that
kind of stuff
but this one this experience was more
existential because obviously my life
was really danger and also I don't know
there was just a deeper sense of this
this coming into contact with death and
this thrill of facing death so anyway so
we get our stuff and and it's so strange
because one of the things that I brought
out that we bought in Burundi it was
this basket if you watch my videos
before and the last few videos I made I
actually put this basket behind me on
the shelf because it it became one of my
most it's one of my most precious
objects just because of just because it
would it represent that moment of facing
death and then you know escaping with
this basket from Africa anyways so so
finally we're in this we're in the guest
house again and the UN cells are gonna
come get us but as they they're coming
the shooting intensifies again once
again so when the UN arrives in front of
the door no one wants to leave except my
wife and I because the car was in
bulletproof as well so we just rush out
the door get into the car me they go
down the hill like swerving they're
going down the street swerving to avoid
bullets you know stray bullet or
whatever I don't even know I guess they
know what they're doing and we arrived
at the UN compound and in the UN
compound the first thing we notice is
that everybody is drunk the workers the
people that are working there all the
expats that had been evacuated everybody
is drunk and it was so surreal you know
because you leave this guesthouse you
come to the UN you think you're coming
to a safe safe place but it was absolute
mayhem it was absolute caps cuz all
these refugees basically were piled into
the the UN compound um and so we we
didn't know where to go we kind of we
slept in this massive room where there
was hundreds of people kind of slept
under a table near the men's bathroom
and it was it's quite disgusting you
know the smell obviously there's
hundreds of people so the smells started
to increase so
Haley it's quite crazy if you guys are
interested in seeing a little bit of
that it turns out that while we were
there in this compound with in Congo we
there was also a famous punk band that
were there and I didn't I saw them from
far away but I didn't know who they were
cuz I was growing up by then didn't know
about these days punk band it's a punk
band called some 41 and they made a
video about it's called rock in Congo so
if you want to check that out you can
actually see it's very strange to watch
like you can watch our experience during
that time you can see the compound you
can see all these all these people that
all this chaos I and anyways so so and
then after that in the next few weeks
after that time finally were evacuated
and we were brought outside of the city
into another city and it was very
interesting because we were just sitting
there we'd left this this war zone you
know and within a few hours now we were
in this calm hotel and everything was
calm but both my wife and I could still
hear massive shooting we can still hear
shooting and war trumpets and all this
stuff but there was nothing there was no
sound we were I mean it was just
traumatism I guess but we couldn't hear
it
you know as if it was there quite
surreal experience and then in the next
few weeks after that a lot of the expats
left Congo but our organization we were
working for Mennonite Central Committee
they tend to evacuate people at you know
really at the last moments like they
don't evacuate just evacuate and so we
ended up going back to Kinshasa where we
were living but we stayed in Kinshasa as
it devolved into riots and we got stuck
in our house for a week with all these
riots going around our house it was
quite intense because we lived in the
local neighborhoods we didn't live in
like white clay he lived in local
Congolese neighborhoods and at some
point this this crowd came to our door
and they they said they were coming
because they heard that there was that
there were white people you know in the
his compound it's so funny because that
this crowd came to the door you know
like angry
because they blame the UN for the war
and they blamed the international
community for the war and so they were
just angry so they came to the door and
they're like we hear there's white
people here you know and our neighbors
who were amazing it was so funny because
I neighbors said no no they're Canadian
and that was enough to dispel the crowd
of angry people and so they dispelled
this crowd and then finally we were
pretty safe in our house people came to
visit us and brought us food and stuff
so we stayed there for about a week and
then we were soon as things died down we
got into our pickup truck and just like
bolted to a compound an American
compound that we knew of but all the
Americans had pretty much gone so we
were kind of alone in this compound it
was just a very intense time several
times in that in those very few weeks I
came like right face to face with the
possibility of of dying after that I was
also once I was arrested by the police
because there were no expats left and so
we became suspicious for the police I
was arrested and I was like I pull a car
came right up against my pickup truck
and like forced me to to move off the
road these guys got into the back and
someone got into the policeman got into
the front and then he started he started
saying that I'm a spy you know and all
this and then he and I just thought he
wanted my money which is ended up being
the case and so he said I need to search
her bag so it's okay fine you want to
search my bag that's fine but I always
kept my money in a in a ziplock bag so I
pulled a ziploc bag out and I said this
is my money I'm gonna put my money in my
pocket and if you want to search my bag
you can search my bag so full take the
bag put it in my pocket
the policeman searches the bag but
obviously he he didn't want he didn't
want searched my bag he wanted my money
so he says I need to count the money I
need to count how much money you had I
was like I'm not I'm not giving you my
money it's not happening I also
obviously now by now also I was just
sick and tired of this like it's like I
didn't care anymore and and so he said I
hate this sketchy I need to count
your money and I said no so then you
actually I can't believe I did this
actually it's quite surreal it really
shows you this kind of thrill that's
kind of weird thrilled it's kind of
reared weird rushed when you come
face-to-face with with death that can
happen he the policeman goes to to put
his hand in my pocket to take the money
out and I like I slap his hand away and
I'm like no you're not going to get my
money I said if you want and can go to
my office which was down the street we
could go inside we can we can we can go
there and then we can talk but here I'm
not doing anything so the policeman
takes his gun out and I just started
laughing I mean but by now you guys if
you know me you've seen that I always
laugh in the most inappropriate moments
and so I just start laughing at the
police officer and I and I'm like are
you gonna shoot me you gonna shoot me
here you're like right here at downtown
in the middle of town you're just gonna
shoot me because you want my money and
I'm like you're not getting anything for
me and I just anyways like I said rush
this this weird rush of energy that you
get someone can I get anything until
finally the policeman backs down and
then it's weird he comes like he turned
into like this weird like a weird beggar
and he started to say yeah but you know
you know we made all this effort you
should at least give us money for cokes
or for beers or something anything from
me I just get out of my car so finally
any of the policemen got out of the car
and that happened several times in those
few weeks I also got got taken into by
police with a guest that he had and I
had to negotiate his release and all
this happened in the span of about I
would say about two weeks all of that
and and I remember the I remember what I
tell you guys I remember this rush this
like rush of this thrill of being face
to face with with danger being face to
face with death being face to face with
with losing everything because it's
almost as if it it's almost as if it
feels like it could be a liberation like
be this weird liberation to kind of go
off the edge and I'm telling you this I
don't I have to admit like I'm telling
you I'm telling you guys this and even
the symbolism I don't I don't totally
understand it I think I grasp it
somewhat I don't totally understand it
but I felt the same now
I felt the same in during the time of
the flood when we were if things happen
very fast the police came and told us we
have to leave now and water was coming
so we had to like get in the car and
leave as the water was rising up in our
in our house and then we came back to
her house you know in a lake basically
our house is flooded and everything is
floating in the basement and and we
don't know where we're gonna go don't
know what we're gonna do and everything
is uncertain and it's the same thing as
we're stripping the basement and I'm
like throwing my books out the window
and I'm and I'm taking all my you know
our kids drawings and and taking them
out the window and all our homeschool
and all my kids my my son's room and
everything and just through the despair
I mean there's despair and obviously
that everybody knows that there's
despair but there's this strange this
strange rush is strange this strange
energy which comes and I and I and I
don't the the intuition that I have okay
this is the intuition that I have is I
think that obviously this is not at the
same level but I think there's something
about Christianity in that there's
something that can be flipped in that
and I and I say that being very careful
when I say that because obviously I
don't know but when you read the
testimonies of the martyrs it seems like
there's something in there where they
ride that they ride that experience in a
in a holy man or let's say like for me
it's not there's nothing holy about that
experience that I had there's nothing
holy about those feelings it's it's
basically just the passions and it's
it's a form of passion really but this
idea that you could ride that that rush
or that thrill you could write it in a
manner which would flip it and make it
into a kind of of glorification you know
and and it's filled when you read some
of the stories of the martyrs of how
they faced death and there
that becomes almost a kind of ecstasy
I'm wondering about that like I'm
wondering if maybe that has something to
do with this experience of coming
face-to-face with with with death coming
face-to-face with with the edge and so
anyways that's a little meditation
that's a little meditation I'm offering
for you guys another thing I wanted to
talk about before I don't want to make
this video too long but another thing I
wanted to talk about was one of the
things I noticed in the in my town as
the these heaps these piles were coming
up is people started to put these weird
mascots in front of their heaps of
rubbish there were few houses where it
almost became like Apple Tropez ik
imagery at what repay ik imagery is the
idea of putting monsters on the edge you
know like putting gargoyles on the edge
of churches or putting fearful creatures
on the outside and one house had this
pile of rubbish and right in front of
the house they put up this little stand
and understand they had a mask of a evil
clown like a kind of Halloween mask of
an evil clown and I was like oh my
goodness there's this is so strange and
appropriate especially with all the Hong
Kong clown world stuff that has been
going on so here's this clown deadly
Count clown mascot you know protecting
or manifesting this heap of rubbish and
chaos there was also someone nearby who
had put up this like weird doll like
like it's kind of monstrous doll that
was up on the top of a water here that
had been taken out of the house and so
it's very fascinating to see that in
this this chaos you know you think about
the people who took their trash out and
obviously there's all this stuff that
everybody's throwing all this stuff away
and so why did they choose it's not
conscious right they didn't they didn't
do it consciously but for sure there was
something happening something about that
mass but just made sense for them to put
there in front of their pile in front of
their heap and I think that this is
sometimes how symbolism happens like in
the in the end of all the possibilities
the one that you end up to
is the one which is closest to reality
which is closed as to what is happening
what is manifested and so it almost has
a ritual shape despite the fact that
this is a common experience this is not
a thought-out ritual or a thought-out
thing and so I thought those are some of
the strange experiences that I've been
having that have been extremely
interesting so anyways so I'm gonna end
this video now guys sorry that these
videos are becoming very personal but uh
just remember you know remembering all
these events in my life as as as my own
life is still in kind of in shambles
right now so hopefully soon I'll come
back to the normal videos and I'll be
able to talk about symbolic things that
aren't so close to me so alright guys so
thanks for your attention thanks again
for everybody that has been supporting
us through prayer through great messages
of encouragement and financially as well
and I will see you soon